and we are following breaking news in
Anguilla in connection with the case of
a Connecticut man who may go on trial
for allegedly killing a hotel worker on
the Caribbean island Scot Hapgood was
vacationing with his family in April
when he says Kenny Mitchell tried to rob
him Mitchell died after a struggle and
Hapgood was charged with manslaughter
Errol Barnett is here with how US
government officials are backing
hapgoods account
Errol what are we learning well good
morning CBS News has now confirmed that
despite being required to attend
Monday's hearing Scott Hapgood is not in
Anguilla and decided against appearing
there now it's unclear how this will
impact the judges pending decision on if
Hopkins manslaughter trial will begin
he's maintained his innocence but people
on the island are angry he hasn't faced
any kind of justice for his alleged
crime we are still in shock that a
simple vacation they look forward to for
so long
turned into a nightmare as Scott Hapgood
faces a potential trial in Anguilla
he has remained adamant that he and his
family's lives were threatened on the
day Kenny Mitchell died Hapgood says on
April 13th
Mitchell entered his hotel room with a
knife demanding money that led to a
physical struggle which resulted in
Mitchell's death a bellman at the hotel
Josh Wayne Clark was one of the first
people to walk into the room during that
fight I take a peek in I saw a Kenny on
his back and mr. Hapgood / Kenny
he says hapgoods forearm was on
Mitchell's neck the initial autopsy
report showed Mitchell died from
positional asphyxia but a toxicology
report obtained by the Hapgood legal
team shows a lethal dose of cocaine
could have killed Mitchell I go back and
forth doing [ __ ] I'm the face of
significant dangers to make sure that
the facts come out because the hard
science shows what really happened the
hapgoods public appeal for help got the
attention of President Trump who said he
would look into the case tweeting
something looks and sounds very wrong
just last week a bipartisan group of
seven lawmakers signed this letter
asking the State Department for a quote
ironclad guarantee of mr. Hapgood safety
and security during his
stay in Anguilla to have the continuing
threat of unfair and possibly secret
criminal proceedings against them should
never happen to any American but
residents of Anguilla are striking a
different tone demanding Hapgood pay a
price for Mitchell's death in August we
spoke to Mitchell's brother Marshall
what would justice look like for as long
as it takes until justice is you take a
life you understand CBS News legal
analyst Ricky Clayman says Hapgood has
benefited from positive press and
government help but she says the
unwilling judge will not allow the US
government to affect the ruling it's one
thing to want to clear your name in the
environment in which you live it's
another thing to actually try to put
pressure on a government of another
country
now with Hapgood a no-show at today's
hearing it raises a number of legal
questions how will the judge react and
might it affect the judge's decision on
moving forward with a trial now there is
an extradition treaty between the u.s.
and the UK of which Anguilla is a
territory but it's just unclear right
now if that will even be necessary
interesting turn of events for mr.
Hapgood because he's always gone back in
the past and I always found that to be
admirable it just doesn't make sense to
me that a hotel guest would kill a
worker on the other side it doesn't make
sense that a worker would kill a hotel
guest over that cocaine factor seems to
change things in this case but a lot of
this has captivated the entire island
which of course realizing the tourism so
we'll see how things progress right
Errol thank you